[MUSIC PLAYING]
CAMERON COLE RAHTZ: I
wanted my prep to be better
and I wanted my
ingredients to be better.
I found myself wanting to
find those ingredients.
I started out as a cook.
I cooked here for years.
Chef would always encourage
me to kind of explore
my curiosities.
And my days off, I'd spend
a lot of time in the woods.
They're just so difficult
to find sometimes.
They blend with the leaves.
They blend with
the woods, which I
think is what like really makes
me love searching for them.
It's like a modern day, like
kind of real adult treasure
hunting.
There's nothing like
the feeling of finding
a beautiful mushroom.
These are the Allium triquetrum,
three-cornered leeks.
I think these are the
best of both worlds
because they're A, delicious;
but B, they're invasive.
These have, just in
this little patch
alone, they've
spread probably 50%
at least in the last few years.
And they're outcompeting all
the native species, along
with other invasives.
It's really hard to serve
something like this whole.
Chef really prefers
them, obviously,
to be small because
it kind of lends
to the restaurant's cuisine a
bit more than the larger ones.
CHRISTOPHER KOSTOW:
The abalone dish
that we're doing right now,
that features the wild onions,
was actually sort of something
that one of my sous-chefs,
John Hong, who's a
very talented guy,
he really kind of
spearheaded that dish
in a earlier form last year.
What it is is it uses
Rancho Gordo beans, which
are these amazing dry beans;
a lot of brown butter;
abalone that's cooked first
in seaweed and then roasted;
and then the wild onions,
which are quickly roasted.
I don't know that we look at
what we're doing necessarily
as a forging endeavor, per se.
Yet there is a
certain element of it
that involves going out into
the woods and getting stuff.
It's about building up your
larder, your physical larder,
but also building up your
wherewithal and your knowledge.
CAMERON COLE RAHTZ: Chef and I
both always saw room for a role
like this.
I found myself wanting to
find those ingredients.
I wanted my ingredients
to be better.
NARRATOR: All Points Project
is a part of "Seeker Stories."
Be sure to check out our
video on pet cafes in Japan.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
NARRATOR: New episodes of All
Points Project every Tuesday.
Be sure to subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]